Netflix has proven just how great they
are at making romantic comedies and they
are releasing another feature in the
heartthrob and Noah sand today oh the
perfect date looks downright amazing and
we can't wait to see what it has in
store for us watch until the end to see
the best behind-the-scenes photos and
the cutest moments from the upcoming
film oh my god that is the perfect date
there's no other way Netflix is latest
rom-com is all about a high school
senior named Brooks Brooks has managed
to get accepted into Yale but he doesn't
know how he'll afford it he gets the
opportunity to take a rich girl on a
date for money it goes so well that he
makes an app with his tech genius friend
all these rich girls who need a date for
events or a responsible chaperone to
hire him he can be anything they want
him to be but along the way he meets the
perfect girl and things get complicated
this movie looks super cute and this
cast has so much chemistry in one
behind-the-scenes video they had a
picnic together they are making fun of
Odysseus Jordy Addis it looks like these
actors became awesome friends and has so
much fun together
Noah sand today Oh plays Brooks he is a
regular kid who was also really smart
and the girl of his dreams is played by
Camila Mendes it must be super awkward
to act as love interests if you don't
like the person we know this often
happens in Hollywood but that is not the
case for Noah and Camila they seem to
really love each other's company check
out this cute photo from the set
they are just chilling together while
they waits for their next scene if Laura
Morana looks familiar it's because she's
played Ally on Disney Channel's Austin
and Ally in the perfect date she plays
Celia Celia is a troubled rebellious
rich girl her cousin hires Brooks to be
her date to a dance
Celia becomes a close friend to Brooks
and their on-screen chemistry is amazing
these two acts like they have known each
other forever and they pretty much have
you might be shocked to learn that a
very young nois Antonio guest-starred on
Austin and Ally Laura Marano posted the
best throwback video ever
that is pretty bad but not worse than
this Noah might have learned how to
dance since his Disney days but we
aren't sure about Laura one of the
cutest moments in the perfect date is
when Brooks gets Celia
let's go shred some heartburn and by
that he means dance but Celia just
doesn't really know how we could not
stop laughing at the scene
this movie is definitely going to make
you fall in love with nois and tane oh
if you haven't already we've already
seen him play the perfect boyfriend into
all the boys I've loved before but in
the perfect date he literally plays a
guy getting paid to be a perfect
boyfriend getting paid but we aren't
sure it's just acting
Noah pretty much seems like the perfect
guy be it as a friend or a boyfriend
this photo shows how good of a friend he
is to Camilla Mendez seriously it takes
a really great guy to give a foot
massage and he just seems so happy about
it
Noah's super smart and according to his
co-star he's really deep as well the
perfect date is full of awesome
sarcastic humor some of these jokes have
us literally laughing out loud did you
know that Michelle Obama got paid to go
on a date with Barack and we are digging
the snarky attitudes of Brooks and Celia
these two are absolutely perfect
together they help bring out the best in
each other - a good friend is one who
isn't afraid to tell you the hard truths
you act so tough it sure looks like
Celia accepts Brooks for who he is
we are definitely sensing a love
triangle here just look at the way she
reacts when he says he wants to date
Shelby I mean my dream come true yeah we
see what you're doing Netflix who
doesn't love a good love triangle but
Laura Marano will neither confirm or
deny if they share an onscreen kiss
guess we'll just have to wait and see
what happens
Oh DC is Jordi a displays Murph he is
Brooks's best friend he is a computer
whiz and is a great at programming he is
the one who builds the stand-in app for
Brooks
Odysseus has had a few small roles but
now everyone will know exactly who this
young actor is the cast if the perfect
date loves to give Odysseus a hard time
but you can tell it's all in good fun
just look at the photo Laura posted on
her social media page
you know it didn't tell her to see us
that they were taking a photo come on
guys that was just not cool but Odysseus
is so awesome that he still looks
amazing Murph is a great friend to
Brooks but Brooks his priorities are
totally out of whack
Murphy isn't afraid to call him out on
it we cannot wait to see how Brooks gets
his life back together we are so excited
about this latest romantic comedy from
Netflix Noah Stanton AO is just blowing
us out of the water and we are so in
love with the rest of the cast
we just know this movie is going to get
us right in the fields but it also looks
so funny this cast is going to be
perfect together just look at how much
they love each other we hope to see a
lot more of these actors in the future
right now Noah is filming the sequel to
all the boys I've loved before Odysseus
has a movie coming out soon too Laura
has filmed the pilots for a show and has
a movie coming out called saving Zoe and
kamila is of course playing Veronica
Lodge on River Dell if you're a fan of
River Dahl you're probably fond of Cole
Sprouse well in that case here's a pic
you didn't know you needed yep that's
right
Noah Sinden AO and Cole Sprouse all in
the same shot turns out Noah's Antonio
is chummy with more than one Riverdale
actor the perfect date is set to
premiere on Netflix on April 12th 2019
will you be watching Nets let us know in
the comments and be sure to tell us
which backstage moment was your
favorites if you loved this video give
us a big thumbs up and don't forget to
subscribe to the things for more awesome
videos we'll see you next time
[Music]